philadelphia eagles will have a new
quarterback
in 2021 because carson wentz has a new
home that's giovanni a 14 year old
podcast a big
fan of wentz and there's number two
carson wentz because he couldn't wear 11
because michael pittman jr said i'm not
giving it up wentz is now number two
and carson wentz uh presumably this week
in a press conference that philadelphia
media
is not invited to how about that i saw
philadelphia reporters complaining about
it yesterday what a shock philadelphia
reporters complaining
could you imagine that but they were
complaining and i think they should have
a seat at the table
or at the zoom session why are you
freezing them out let them ask
some questions this is a news conference
it shouldn't be exclusive only
to the reporters who will put their nose
in the right spot when asking the
questions
so i got a problem with that presumably
he'll talk about why he's picked number
two
giovanni breaking the news that once
will be number two in indianapolis yeah
that's that's hey cool i'm you know me i
like the
i like quarterbacks who wear number two
i definitely do uh one plus one is two
he wore eleven
now he's got two okay that's cool i'm
down with that i i have never heard of
that though like
they're and this is news to me i i
didn't know this until you just said it
but they're not going to let philly
anybody from the philly media be
involved with this conversation that
that to me is a little odd there's no
doubt about that are they just letting
colts indianapolis people around the
team or is there other
there's no other cities or national
media that's allowed
i don't know whether to what extent
national media is involved
a lot of these press conferences happen
without
anyone involved nationally and
and look this is it's i'm going to get
myself in trouble but i i don't care i'm
old enough that
i i'll gladly get myself in trouble
because it's the truth here's what
happens
in a lot of cities i'm not going to say
all but in a lot of cities there's a
there's a comfortable relationship
there's a quid pro
right your job is to cover the team you
help us cover the team
and we won't be buttholes that's kind of
the loose understanding and the smaller
the market
the more effective that arrangement can
be so
it makes it easier for everyone if you
don't have now sometimes it's
unavoidable as we saw with urban meyer
when he got his introduction to the nfl
and he was peppered with questions about
the misguided hiring of chris doyle
i'm not saying that there are kid gloves
at all times but
you're not going to have any of the
philly media who would be destroying
carson wentz with questions about what
went wrong and why it went wrong
because he's managed to avoid any of all
of it i know
any of it once he got benched he didn't
have any regular media obligations and
he was able to avoid it because there's
no locker room access
last year because of the pandemic the
pandemic has helped because chris in a
normal year what would happen is
it would be an open press conference
sure and it would be extremely awkward
if the cults denied access to
credentialed members
right of the philadelphia media who were
making the trip
to indianapolis to ask questions
face-to-face of carson wentz they would
have a very hard time getting away with
that yeah it's a lot easier getting away
with it
in the era of zoom press conferences no
definitely and i mean you're right mike
there's this is
i scratch your back you scratch my back
type of you know
relationship with the local media a lot
of the times
you know as a whole we'll make these
players available this coach
this coach is available and then the
media knows
you know not to cross the line maybe in
you know
total defamation of a football team or
anything like that
it's fair and honest criticism when
criticism is deserved
hey look we deal with it you think we're
ever going to have david cully or jack
easter b or nick casario on this show
hell no we're at the forefront of sam
what a mess that team is because it is a
mess
it is a mess well yeah and and we go and
we go into it with eyes open
that they're going to freeze us out
there's plenty of other people they can
talk to and here's the other twist and
this leads into the next point
right when all of these teams have their
own in-house
media operation where the person who's
interviewing you
is a co-worker who reports to the owner
just like the person
that they're interviewing does there's
definitely not going to be any tough
questions
and when howie roseman the gm of the
eagles finally spoke
about this trade it wasn't in a press
conference although presumably he'll
have one at some point it was to
wait for it the team website the
exclusive
which i always refer to it as as an
interoffice meeting
because that's what it is you're two
people commonly employed
by the same person and you're having a
conversation that's being
being touted as an actual interview
there's no independence whatsoever the
person's getting a paycheck from jeffrey
lurie this has been going on for 20
years and i'm the only one that seems to
care about it and
maybe i shouldn't care about it but uh
that's that's what we saw yesterday so
we have a quote board of what harry
roseman said but trust me
it's mean it's worthless he may as well
just written it out
and and submitted it that's what happens
when you get interviewed by a team
website you're never going to have
a tough probing question because if you
ask a tough probing question
you're in trouble here it is it's
written up he submitted it there you go
bam yeah can you if you can read there
you go you don't want to read that there
it is
there's nothing there it's not it's
pointless it's pointless but
point i will say this like okay jack
easterby's definitely not coming on this
show i
know that yeah you've ended that for
sure i don't
nick casario and and david cully i would
hope that we haven't said anything bad
about them we've talked about the
organization as a whole
but it's not their fault that's
certainly not so i would hope not
i think nick's a pretty honest fair guy
just in my you know
years i can work him with i can i can
look i can come up with a list
of of people that we would not get on
the show
you kirk cousins comes on every super
bowl and by all things you would think
he wouldn't come on to talk to you
he just maybe just doesn't watch and you
know what he wants that check from sleep
number one
he wants that check from sleep now we're
ain't gonna say no he watches
his number because he made you smash
eggs over your head so he watches he
knows that's true
um but but but look hey and that that's
fine because my only obligation is to
you not you
chris you the audience to be honest and
authentic and true
and uh and it's because it's not like
any of our criticism is unfair
even the derrick carr criticism oh you
hate derek carr why do you have a
prominent derek carr no
there's just things about derek carr
that i think need to be fairly
criticized and somebody needs to do it
we can't just shake pom-poms if there
are other programs you can watch
coincidentally at this same time if you
want a bunch of
pom-poms shaking praise everyone in
sight that's not what we do
because that's not real that's not real
we're not part of this
chris to just praise everyone we praise
those who deserve it and we criticize
those who deserve it yeah
we talk about the issues that need to be
talked about that's right that's that's
how i i try to
approach the job with you know the
knowledge i have with the sport studying
the sport
you know oh this narrative about this
football team you know is out there
no i i've i've been taught football by
these people and watched the film that's
wrong the narrative's wrong
you know that's i do i feel like that is
you know our duty a little bit there's
no doubt
we're not part of the the propaganda
machine here we respect everybody but
we're we're gonna tell the truth and
and and let everybody know some of the
facts that maybe other people might not
and i know the people who are directly
employed by the league or by the teams
would say well you're employed by one of
the broadcast partners so you're part of
it too but uh
well we're still on the air and we still
say what we believe
and what we feel and will criticize
whoever needs to be criticized i don't
think they always love us though
i'm sure wow they let it go they let it
go
but i don't think i always love it let's
not peel the curtain back
as far as we could let's just leave it
at that uh
there is something that howie roseman
said yesterday that i thought
was very uh intriguing even though it
was to a co-worker
he doesn't rule out drafting a
quarterback at number six
overall now when the report came out
that jeffrey lurie the owner of the team
and this was a chris mortenson report
once jalen hurts to have a chance to be
the guy
it seemed to rule out a quarterback at
number six
and now how he's saying i can't rule it
out look i
you never want to tell the truth in
advance of the draft you never want the
truth to leak and you never want to tell
the truth
and maybe they have ruled out a
quarterback
and they hope by saying we're not ruling
out a quarterback
someone will jump in front of them and
draft a quarterback and push down the
board
one of the guys they really want that
that's the very loose
psychology as the draft approaches
you want the teams in front of you to
take the guys you don't want
so hey i can't rule out a quarterback
please i hope five quarterbacks are
taken
before we pick at number six because
then we essentially have the first pick
in the draft because we're not taking a
quarterback anyway so
always always filter anything you
hear either directly or through leaks
right through that prism of
you're ultimately in this process of you
know where you're picking and everyone
else knows where you're picking and
everyone else is thinking do we need to
get ahead of your spot here
in round one wherever it may be and
that's right so that's why i take
all of it with a grain of salt this time
of year yeah and yes we have to fill our
content quota
and it's newsy to talk about it but but
we don't just pass it along as gospel
we say it should be regarded as
as bs the exact opposite of gossip well
yeah there's your angle like you're
talking about
and there's just the angle of saying
like hey we might draft the quarterback
in number six hoping that somebody at
you know pick seven eight or nine might
go oh man there's this quarterback on
the board we don't know what the eagles
are going to do
and now they trade you know a king's
ransom to get that pick and the eagles
go down a few picks and they go well we
were never going to draft a quarterback
anyways this is great
you know so there is you got to take
that with a grain of salt right now
certainly uh i the the thing at one
point in that regard too because
we always assume i think not we i think
fans assume when there's a trade
like a flip-flop yeah that the flip that
the the team that's dropping down a spot
and letting the other team go up a spot
knows who that team is taking they they
often don't remember the 49ers didn't
know right they didn't know that the
bears were taking mitchell trubisky when
they did the 2-3 flip-flop four years
ago right no they
you're right they didn't i mean i think
that's you know definitely a real thing
there's times where those kind of trades
go down and
the team that trades down doesn't know
exactly who that other team's gonna pick
uh but but i i will say this you know
and i know i said this a few weeks ago
i mean again drafting a quarterback at
number six
and jalen hurts has inserted himself
as you know a part of the dna of the
football team right now
you know he's working with the eagles
receivers and doing that type of stuff
to me you draft a quarterback at six and
you got jalen hurts still on the roster
well welcome to the carson wentz saga
part two i mean that's what you're gonna
be
playing with so that's where i don't
totally buy it you know and i'll say
what i said i think the last time
if they draft a quarterback in number
six then they need to trade jalen hurts
because that to me is not
that's a recipe for disaster you're just
you're you're playing with fire once
again so we'll see what they do but
you know the eagles i look at them as a
team and kind of a total rebuild here uh
for the 2021 season
they still need a viable backup they
regard the backup quarterback as a top
15 spot on the overall roster the
question is what kind of a backup
are you getting are you getting a backup
who is competing
actively every step of the way to be the
starter
or are you getting a backup who truly is
the backup the nick falls back up who
hey i'm just here to play
if the starter gets injured and i still
don't rule out nick foles making his way
back
to philadelphia i hear you'll be the
third time nine years after he was a
third round pick
his third stint with the philadelphia
eagles because i think he'd be the
perfect backup to jaylen hurts
because he's not going to compete to be
the starter he's going to be there to
help
jalen hurts learn the ropes and become
the quarterback
best quarterback he can possibly be
chris yeah agreed agreed and i'm with
you i'm not i wouldn't put that out of
the realm of possibilities yet either i
mean they don't
doesn't they don't have a legitimate
backup on the roster right now
and then that that's gotta bother them a
little bit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports